one face or body yeah if you had to
choose you'd say like you know in an
alternate universe or whatever yeah like
you have to pick a guy and like Ivory is
gonna have a nice face and his body is
just like now or vice versa he's got a
nice face or nice body or nice body or
nice face and why do you pick that so
I'm gonna start with you face your body
be real
you're just gonna throw the body in the
bin
oh oh
you have to hope
listen in this scenario you can't help
him it's just this and this is for life
forever I have to wake up to you but I
can't be scared every morning like to
that face I need to be able to see you
like the body thing like you're gonna
see his body as well you know but close
if it's bad I will be able to just be as
long still okay so as long as his face
is pretty that's all that matters it's
not all that matters the body should be
nice too but you said one another oh
okay all right fair enough what about
you face your body as we say in Brazil I
love Browns but I rather for a pretty
face because a pretty face can lose
weight can go to the gym but someone no
this guy can't change he can't do
nothing like every time I ask this
no not this time he he stuck pretty face
pretty face and just
just this body's just dead
I think like you kiss the face more than
the body so okay yeah
all right just pearly things what do you
think face or body okay I have a couple
questions
did he got any drugs to achieve this
body huh no I'm finding out that a lot
of guys do steroids I didn't know this
was a thing this is something I found
out recently yeah I'm the big deal okay
so no drugs to achieve this no no
gadgets no gadgets just got a goodbye
okay I'm gonna pick the body let me tell
you why because because
I'm thinking he's got to have work ethic
and discipline to get that body right
and I'm really tall and I just can't you
know it's what you can't look I can't go
that much shorter if like if you're
gonna say his body's bad I'm assuming
he's a lot shorter than me right because
that's part of body whatever bad body
yeah so to me it's like okay one I need
my sons to be tall you know what I mean
like I need them I this is a prime gene
pool right here this one's all making
faces
it's too late yeah you put your face
there you go like you know faces we're
gonna get old we're all gonna have ugly
faces in 20 30 years but the body you're
in control of so if you go for the guy
with the good body he's got work ethic
and we can have some prime D1 children I
don't want to go watch no Benchwarmers
play we breed athletes in this family
selective breeding I'm a part of that
what about that still no I agree that
you know what you know tell me about
that yeah actually I'm going to say
after so what do you think face or body
absolutely body okay
um it's unfortunate I'm following her
because we come from the same she comes
from my gene pool I learned from the
best yeah we don't we don't want our
gene pool water down no like we're uh
this is just the way it is like you just
and if they're taking care of their body
they're going to be healthy longer I
don't want to be a nurse I didn't go
into nursing school so I don't want that
you know my dad told me once I was like
Dad you know what should I look for in a
day or if not a dad and a partner right
like what should I look for in a guy he
said the number one thing you should
look for is in hell is health because
otherwise you got to take care of them
but it's not everyone can keep it a nice
body maybe it's a time of their life
they're passing through there it's just
one another what kind of choices they
make you know what I mean like I'm not
we have a Ronaldo defense here's a
simple like great athlete but I mean
talking about this with my friend
earlier in the gym yeah and it was like
I used to say face like you look I
changed my mind bro change my mind yeah
body man especially from a guy's point
of view
man if the face is nice yeah that's
that's lovely that's lovely you know I
mean okay sir yeah oh yeah but bro like
if the body's not there bro like as for
a man yeah that's that's I mean the face
is gonna go in like 10 20 years anyway
for them you know it's like for the most
part so I feel like body overall yeah
the body can get you from when you're 60
70 how how good is your face really
gonna be hey I'm getting close to 60.
Mom I'm sorry I don't know what to tell
you wow
[Laughter]
oh Matt all right cool all right in the
chat let me know what you think face
your body in it let me know and all of
that good stuff also make sure you
hitting the like button do not forget to
do that yeah very important metric that
YouTube uses
and let everybody know that they love
what they see here yeah all right cool
so today we are talking about
um why modern women prefer to be mothers
than wives
yeah why modern women prefer to be
mothers than wives and I'm gonna ask the
guess what they think about that title
that so when you hear that title what
comes to your mind
it's not me
not much just it's there's pure baby
mums out there and not much weddings
going on that's what the first thing I
thought of I know it sounds bad but it's
not mad it's real but yeah that's what
it sounded like to me yeah
do you find that D was it like kind of
like oh that's a bit like rude or did
you find it to be rude or
no
I don't think it was really just
different parts of life in it like okay
all right fair enough Wicked uh what
about you what do you think about the
title modern women prefer to me Mothers
than wives I think it depends on the
culture let's say the European women
would rather be a
a woman I think Americans and Brazil are
going to be a mother priority became the
child became the first priority in her
life
as soon zero became a mother so it came
as the more responsibility there the men
normally have
so
it depends I would rather say like it's
not an option when you have a child
the whole society
you are the mother and in let's say if
you have a divorce and you are the one
walking away what a bad mother you are
so a lot of stigma in the society we
need to be the mother and the main carry
of the child so do you think don't you
think men get bad stigma as well when
they walk away from their children
not as much as women
women don't really have the opportunity
to walk away like that and women women
intrinsically on uh you know
instinctively don't want to walk away
from children whereas a man basically he
could like for instance a man could
impregnate all the women in this room
and basically walk away whereas you're
gonna be stuck with the embryo growing
inside you so again don't you think men
usually get a bad rep if they walk away
from their children not as much as a
woman I think like I would love to be a
father I would have ten thousand
children you'd love to be a father and
have ten thousand children
what if women naturally it's like you
think right we have this in natural
intrinsic like we want to be mothers
right however there's so many women
getting their kids nowadays I mean
there's so many girls with their their
womb may as well be a graveyard honestly
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible